Formula One the Super Bowl conventions
it's really not too surprising that the
150 000 plus hotel rooms will be booked
out for these really large scale events
but data shows nearly 2 000 hotel rooms
remain vacant rather jobs eight news now
reporter Ryan Matthey explains how some
hotels are filling that Gap and what
others say needs to happen
[Music]
security food and beverage it's always
been a bit of a challenge but
particularly now even more so Gordon
Prouty with the Westgate Resort and
Casino says filling those positions
became more difficult post pandemic oh
it's going to continue to get more
difficult as more and more properties
are opening particularly a large
property nearby that's going to be uh
you know competing for hires as well so
to compete they've increased how much
pay some employees get up front it used
to be 80 percent of contract at higher
and it would take you a couple of years
to get to the 100 level we're offering
that right from the start and on any
given day one in six people throughout
the community will be a tourist
according to research and with
competition out of every corner
different hotels are providing different
incentives to attract that talent to
work for them
as of Monday indeed.com reports more
than 1800 vacant Hotel positions in and
around the strip Which is less than half
a full percentage point of all
hospitality jobs in the valley and
people are not stupid they're pretty
smart even so Stephen Miller with UNLV
Center for business and economic
research says there are more jobs open
than people looking to fill them workers
have gotten more power in the labor
market which means employers have to
become more Innovative in terms of
attracting employees they're going to
have to share the pie and as Ted Papa
George with The Culinary Union says more
pay increase paid time off and a better
quality of work life are what employees
are looking for and if I'm going to be a
room cleaner which is the big need I
know that I'm not stuck there I have an
opportunity to promote and move my way
up